[Musik]
mein Name ist major Hibler Harald ich
bin hauptleoffizier für infantri am
Institut Jeger und darf sie hier in
dertios kierne in Kaiser Steinbruch
begrüßen äh hier findet gerade die
ortskampfausbildung Einsatz im urbanen
Umfeld der Kaderausbildung 5 statt die
Kaderausbildung 5 Jäger ist die
Ausbildung für den zukünftigen
Infanterie Zugskommandanten in der
Jägertruppe und stellt die hochwertigste
Ausbildung für die Unteroffiziere im
Bereich der waffenkartung Jäger
[Musik]
da
mein Name Manuel Dienstgrad
Oberwachtmeister bin 30 Jahre alt komm
aus Straß Steiermark dort versehe ich
auch meinen Dienst beim
17zeen links rechts
[Musik]
mehrere die Ausbildung dauert 18 Wochen
und soll die Inhalte zur Führung des
Gefechts auf Ebene des jägerzugs
vermitteln um die zukünftigen
Zugskommandanten für ihre folgende
einsatzaufgabe fit zu
[Applaus]
machen für meinen Platz als
zugskommandant in meiner heimatganision
dass ich als zugskommandant meine Truppe
übernehmen kann die besteht ca aus 40
Soldaten davon vier
[Musik]
Gruppenkommandanten